you thought you could win
there is so much coming out this week
but don't worry we have the top Rex
right here for you two movie premieres
if you want to get your butts in a
theater seat and two streaming choices
for those who might prefer the couch and
one special date night pick that you may
not have seen coming Rotten Tomatoes has
got you covered on this week's what to
watch
you will bring me what I need
or everything you call a life will end
finally hitting feeders is the third
installment in the Ant-Man Trilogy
Marvel Studios Ant-Man and the wasp
quantumania and here are not so tiny
reasons why you need to catch this one
this weekend Jonathan Majors performance
as Kang the Conqueror the mcu's next big
bad has everyone absolutely raving take
this review from critic Rohan Patel of
comicbook.com who says Jonathan Majors
brings the heat making a rapturous debut
as Kang the Conqueror a new Dynasty has
begun and it's time to Bear witness and
not only does the film kick off phase
five of the MCU it sets up and leads
into the next Avengers film phase sixes
Avengers the Kang Dynasty releasing in
2025 and speaking of setups do not skip
out on the two amazing post-credits
scenes at the end of the film
next up slicing and dicing its way into
theaters is the independent slasher film
Winnie the Pooh Blood and Honey I never
thought I'd say that if it isn't obvious
already a good reason to check this one
out is that it's a horror take based on
the famous children's book and animated
show and I'm gonna go and say something
a little crazy this is Pooh bear like
you've never seen him before but wait
until I tell you this wild synopsis in
Blood and Honey having to deal with
Christopher Robin growing up and moving
to college who and piglet feeling angry
and abandoned become feral and thus
bloodthirsty murderers looking for a new
source of food oh bother I'm gonna take
a billion dollars and aim it in your
direction
arriving on Apple TV plus this week is
the drama film sharper from director
Benjamin Karen one of the biggest
reasons to check this one out is a
killer star-studded cast which includes
Julianne Moore who also served as a
producer John Lithgow Justice Smith and
Sebastian Stan who is by the way the
center of this very intriguing plot he
stars as a con man who goes after
Manhattan's billionaires as a way to
exact revenge on a family that doesn't
accept him you hadn't yet Sebastian Stan
this is life or death it's always life
or death John Luke when has it not been
taking off on Paramount Plus for the
last time in its third season is Star
Trek Picard the main reason you gotta
check this one out is that it is indeed
the final season of the show which began
in 2020 as a follow-up to one of the
most beloved Star Trek series Star Trek
the Next Generation and speaking of TNG
the season is set to be a major Next
Generation Reunion with series veterans
LeVar Burton Michael Dorne and Gates
McFadden returning to their iconic roles
playing Jack
and finally if you are celebrating
Valentine's day this week then boy do we
have a Saving Grace for you it's James
Cameron's Blockbuster Juggernaut Titanic
back in theaters for its 25th
anniversary and I'm already falling at
how old I am if that isn't enough it's
one of the greatest movies of all time
Not only was it the first movie in
history to cross the billion dollar Mark
at the box office it also swept Awards
season by winning 11 Oscars including
best picture and Best Director oh and
that Celine Dion song Forever a banger
okay hopefully our Rex helps you fill up
your entertainment calendar for this
week be sure to let us know what you
watched whether it was on this list or
not and remember to check in on
rottentomatoes.com for updates on the
latest scores and reviews until next
week have a happy week of watching and
stay fresh
thank you
[Music]